今日は豚のステーキだって集めごめんね音なら技術頑張っていっ
はーい今日ハードル社長です皆さん小泉という枷してますでしょうかから箱で申し訳
ないんですけどこういうお菓子です味が猫色々あるんですけども
ポイポイ楽しい元気の種なんとコラーゲンが入っております雨でて北大井する
だーいすきなんですよこのサイズなんでもなんか美味しいしくっても来てもとまんねー
みたいな感じでちょい1学校跡全然足りないって可能
原理くれる気がしますというで今日はこちらにポイフル参戦分準備してしまいました
[音楽]
準備してしまったものはよろしくない今日はちょっとこの25歳成人弾点が今季出すと
恋するなあと
くれるのかという袋の限界に挑戦してみたいと思いますさあ皆さんみなさん待って
ください体に悪いとは思うじゃないですかでもこれ
コラーゲンが入ってるんですよつまり食えば食うほど僕はきれいになっちゃくがやって
一利なし
いらっしゃいますそれぞれに来ておくてもいいことがあるんで
僕はやりますよだけど7ぽいくるよたくさん食べようと思った人はそういないと思うん
で
割とこれがあの世界記録になると思いますまあこれは下旬に皆さんもぜひあんまりが
ない程度にやってみてはいかがでしょうか
ではよろしくお願います2 e トゥ
うわぁ2ちっ
tano
ん
par
me
[音楽]
wh
ねぇ
me
[音楽]
なんかまたママイスですうまいんですけどされど組なんでちょっと神に時間をください
今城子ニャー15でも全然いけます
[音楽]
ん
濮陽810円はいっ
[音楽]
持った
のルンルン余儀なくが76うん
1いいね
ん
[音楽]
が100あと端から子ですよこれをぶりですあのおいしいの全然いいんですけど
口の中が痛いんじゃいるのかコーンと時と同じこと言ってる
a も白い象じゃんというピンクや驚きを隠せないすごいがなめてた
なぜだ様子お姉さん歳今100ですキャー
います
すごいでっん
おおおおおおおおおおおおおおお
me
ん
[音楽]
本くらいすでに胃袋的に置いなれ寿司食いたいっていが広くず家ましたねそんなことは
俺に取っただそうだ
me
ていた
can you do
me
やっほー
やばいまじ山へ
[音楽]
はぁ
ああ
[音楽]
バーイ
ああああああ
あああああああっ
キャンプラベルのかよね
me
[音楽]
気に入っていっ
まだ水
フラワー
シーン
道
walk
ゲイツ
ハイツ
きゅいー
ジェブ
12位
they さん
水 c
10足かー
うがっっ
うんあ
ようやく超えると運動すると歯企業も4ずになります
h
い
[音楽]
水
ロン
[音楽]
まあ
うううう
[音楽]
me
uh
うううう
me
やって投げてポリポリして食べるの楽しかったんですだだその他の誰にちょっと惑わさ
れてて気づいたら448個食べていまして
ちょっと運動さだも良くなかったんですけどもうちょっと僕の記録は448号でした
ちなみやり投げて食べる記録は14が僕の記録です
土台